mais franchement le n'est qu'il est pas
promet ouais ça me fait hier sa roue
comment ils vont la
sortir
tu as été une année de chiottes n'a fait
que de la merde tu nous as tous foutu la
honte moi j'ai fait mon taf tranquille
lui aussi toi rien à [ __ ] quoi à ces
vents n'importe quoi tu faisais
confiance le 31 décembre s'est passé le
flambeau à tout gâcher tu as tout [ __ ]
tout mon travail que j'ai accumulé notre
travail même si ça reste que l'équipe
s'arrête c'est un team building bref
tous les goûts tout s'éclaire faire tu
abuses de ouf la hâte en 2021 n'existe
pas encore en fait je vous remercie bon
allez je ferme ma gueule et les mecs
n'exagérez pas non plus j'ai quand même
fait quelques trucs bien ah bon comme
quoi
pas par exemple j'ai fait rentrer dans
lectionnaire le mot pavlova c'est un
gâteau fait très très bon alors déjà
comme news c'est à chier et en plus ça
c'était moi instant 2019 bon boulot à
moi c'est toi ça j'étais pas sûr ouais
c'était passion par contre toi pandémie
mondiale un maximum de confinement des
grèves des conflits gilet jaune du
racisme de partout des violences
policières ok c'est bon c'est bon on a
compris je rappelle quand même que le
pangolin c'est pas moi qui les bouffer
c'est lui quoi le pongol un sétois ouais
ouais c'est moi c'est moi qui mange un
paraguay mais c'était en décembre après
c'est lui qui a tout amplifié à il a
vraiment foutu un bordel mondiale donc
voila moi j'ai juste mon chien un petit
bongo la llc bon les gars vous êtes
tendu vous êtes stressé et c'est normal
fini on repart de zéro on fait la paix
gestes-barrières
geste quoi gestes barrières
le tombé connais pas ouais 2016 fait pas
trop le malin ce que je te rappelle que
tu as quand même tué mohamed ali david
bowie prins et j'en passe c'est toi qui
ose me dire ça alors que tu as été
l'année la plus meurtrière la plus
meurtrière thani est ce que c'est
vraiment de quoi tu me parles montée
connard ouais pardon c'est vrai que vu
comme ça mais c'est vrai que ce petit
groupe d'année là il peut vraiment la
merde ah bah merci ça fait toujours
plaisir d'y encore cette fois je te
marie bourre pif
[Musique]
[ __ ] j'adore jimi hendrix et les mecs
on va commencer à chercher qui est la
meilleure ou la pire année on est tous
un peu bien est tous un peu pas bien ok
c concept de l'ombre et de la lumière
c'est le concept du ying et dur
qui veulent jampy parce que j'en ai un
maximum sans trop bon je suis
entièrement d'accord avec le babos égard
on peut pas résumer une année à un seul
événement c'est pas possible la la la la
la la la ouais je sais dès qu'on pense à
98 on pense à coupe du monde de foot et
dès qu'on prend sa coupe du monde de
foot on pense à 90 buts mais je préfère
que ça j'ai aussi fait le défilé sur les
champs légion d'honneur pour les bleus
est aussi une chanson là non voici j'ai
gagné la coupe du monde de foot mais moi
te montrer
à 98 est passé de thunes pour acheter
mais vrai maillot away le malien
officielle et coûtait 300 francs 300
francs ah ouais tu as tu date vraiment
y'a pire un regard lui
[Musique]
mais lui c'est lui c'est une [ __ ]
à c'est quoi ce bruit là a fait mal aux
tympans
maman la tecktonik c'est pas juste une
phase ok c'est toute ma vie je veux
devenir pro allô allô plus de forfaits
quelqu'un au téléphone ouais tiens
[Musique]
pourquoi tu la rose sont pas une plante
pas si dieu me prête hydroalcoolique je
connais pas cette drogue salaire énorme
droit dans ses bottes aux pommes c'est
comme le lsd ou ya un pas de touche
c'est ridicule c'est quoi bah c'est un
smartphone quoi appareils photos et
vidéos 4k triple objectif puisse
bionique à 14 reprises en strass yal
étanche 4g et bientôt 5 g ah ouais quand
même alors justement par rapport aux
effets secondaires de la 5g moi je les
connais un peu et c'est pas terrible un
tas le complotistes alors et de suez à
snake eyes dessus tu peux mettre des
jeux rétro plein de trucs et même un vpn
nord vpn permet non seulement du navire
en toute sécurité sur tous les réseaux
wifi publics mais également de
contourner tout légers aux restrictions
très simplement et rapidement contourner
les règles en accédant à des jeux vidéo
des films des séries les programmes tv à
des tarifs avantageux en changeant votre
localisation ou simplement avant tout le
monde comme si vous étiez partout dans
le monde devenait rebelles et en plus
noir et pn bloque les pubs et les
malwares génial j'ai rien compris mais
c'est énorme
et lequel d'entre eux voient inventé le
placement de produits en
tout cas le futur c'est beau
le cas bob le futur c'est moi comme ça m
à comprendre
c'est 2340 et que tu claques alors c'est
pas moi 2340 moi je suis son assistant
un peu comme ce que vous appeliez
l'époque une sorte de syrie quoi papa le
pays a eu et les ou du cou des 1340 lui
ah bah comme tous les humains il est
mort est remplacé par un robot a de quoi
vous parlez je comprends rien [ __ ] ils
sont fous ici
là ouais vous avez tous nikki la planète
pollution disparition des espèces et les
changements climatiques donc ce qui fait
la morale à 2020 vous êtes tous autant
des grosses merdes quoi vous allez vous
y la planète avec vos citroën cx evo mob
je suis dégouté je vais écrire à son nom
c'est une maison bleue aucun rapport à
chansons en fait heureusement il nous
reste le livre pour ne rappeler des plus
grands ce que marqué l'humanité comme
norman non non bah ouais norman le chan
ok jenner c'est une légende s'est amusé
à oui
je te connais ce chien je mange les
mêmes requêtes
ouais je me casse je n'ai plus rien à
[ __ ]
il est quand même bien casser l'ambiance
grecque oui j'accepte aouf bond 2020
allons bientôt but c'est quoi tes bonnes
résolutions ouais alors moi c'est à lui
qu'il faut demander ça a donc ce serait
à moi de réparer toutes les conneries de
ce mec n'importe quoi et 2022 à savoir
moi non mais coeur et jean rivard a
capté chao 2020 bonjour 2022 du coup ou
quoi
[Musique]
et
un jour
pourquoi sur son tee shirt ses écrits je
suis la première année le point de
départ
votre guide
pour qui se prend lui c'est quoi ce
style de jésus version wii cela je suis
la première année c'est la préservant un
peu comme le patient zéro à spa la bonne
image mais vous avez compris quoi je
suis venu vous dire qu'il ne faut pas
juger trop sévèrement les années car
c'est à cause et grâce à elle nous
sommes ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
oui c'est parfois dur il faut les
accepter ainsi le chaos et les échecs
font partie des leçons de la vie qui
font qu'on se relève plus fort qu'on
avance vers l'avenir et qu'on progresse
on n'a pas tort le vieux aussi pris une
claque là je me suis pris une claque de
la vérité en fait c'est comme ça que
l'univers a toujours fonctionné et
continuera à fonctionner longtemps donc
ne soyez pas trop dur avec 2020 parce
que les années qui arrivent seront
peut-être plus prospère
[Musique]
attendez on finit vraiment là-dessus là
le truc hyper anxiogène tout le monde à
la croûte au cul merci panoramix à même
d'écouter le mail à temps c'est pas ma
faute finir aussi sur une note positive
a comme moi un petit bonhomme et à c'est
pas con ça allez je me lance bon alors
ça c'est à moi de le dire à partir de
minuit dans sa porte malheur et des
malheurs 2020 quant à fait assez comme
ça alors c'est quoi moi tu m'a saoulé on
va régler ça entre bonhomme
taissy quoi
[Musique]
pas la gauche
voilà comme ça tu pourras plus tard des
conneries et tu pourras plus rien dire
jeunesse nous vous
offrons
bien ouej 2021 ah non non juste barrière
banon où on peut
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo petit
offres de noël que l'on répète
évidemment tout abonnement de deux ans
en titre et une réduction de 60 8% c'est
très précis et de quatre mois
supplémentaires gratuits et lors de
votre achat rentrer mon code promo qui
est le poids des tartiflettes et
pourquoi
pour sa rendez vous ici toutes les infos
sont évidemment de destruction ciao